now um i'm sort of bending the rules a
little bit i'm going to show you a
result i'm going to prove it to you in a
very very quick way um that is suitable
for where you're at mathematically there
are more sophisticated proofs for it so
you'll just have to trust me for now
okay would you please draw from me a
triangle right angle
like so
doesn't have to be beautiful doesn't
even have to be that big i would like to
make its hypotenuse one
and i'm just going to call this angle
over here in the corner just going to
call it theta that's a pretty standard
name for angles that i don't know what
they're equal to
all right now on the basis of this
information okay
i would like to know what is this side
over here what is the length of this
side now you have very little
information you don't even know the size
of the angle okay but
it's trigonometric fallacy right so you
can use some trig to help you it's a
right angle triangle okay so suppose let
me just call this side x okay i don't
know what it is
but look you see trigonometric knowledge
what kind of expression equation i
should say could you write on the basis
of what you know here
okay you look at the two sides you got
in relation to the angle it's opposite
and hypotenuse right so that's sine
isn't it okay so i can say sine theta
equals
x
x over 1 that's the ratio which of
course is just x
so now i know what this side is equal to
it's equal to
sine theta whatever that happens to be
are you comfortable with that idea you
see that so i'm just going to relabel
that
just going to call that sine theta
because x equals sine theta
okay without writing anything down
and not having to call this like a
letter
what do you think this is equal to
it's the it's the adjacent side right
let me show you the steps just in case
you're not sure let's call it something
else right
adjacent hypotenuse right so cos theta
is adjacent
over hypotenuse just one
y equals cos theta
so i'm just going to relabel that
happy times you right so far
okay
cool now by the way as i said just like
with this proof if you see the aha
moment okay don't spoil it for everyone
there's actually a couple of different
moments you have to watch out for right
just process it maybe make a mental note
for yourself like aha here's where it is
okay is that all right so so far so good
now have a look at this it's a right
angle triangle right so more than just
all this trig stuff you can make some
statements on it based on the fact that
it's right angle what might you say
okay you've got pythagoras here right
what does pythagoras tell you in this
particular triangle
very good
sine squared plus cos squared
equals one okay now i have given you the
quick and dirty proof for this i've
drawn you a triangle okay but this is
actually a very important result this is
not the problem by the way this is a
this is a well-known result in fact it's
called the the pythagorean identity
because it comes from
pythagoras okay so this is this is true
you can get a whole bunch of variations
on this if you divide through by cos
squared or divide through by sine
squared
aside from the point yes
sure okay so that's just a matter of
notation um i want to avoid this kind of
situation which is kind of ambiguous
because am i am i squaring the theta or
am i squaring the sine theta the whole
thing right so when i say
this
i mean this
okay
because even though the whole thing is
squared so really i should put it over
there it's so common to do this and i
want to avoid brackets because as you'll
see in a second sometimes i'm doing
backwards flying everywhere so if i can
minimize them that's the idea so that's
just a little bit of notation for you so
far so great
now get ready i'm going to start playing
around
first thing i'm going to do remove this
guy card over the other side right so
cos a squared equals 1 minus
sine squared
okay
um that's a square okay so just for the
sake of it i'm going to take the square
root of both sides
okay remember if you see something skip
to yourself for now
that's fine both are positive like
positive positive so far so good okay
ah but
theta right theta is an angle i don't
know what the angle is so i can actually
put different angles into them let me
just give you an example consider
what would happen if theta were 180
degrees
okay what would happen now the thing is
you can use calculator but hopefully you
know a little bit about sine and cos to
actually know what these what they're
equal to when theta is equal to 180
degrees okay have you guys seen your
trig graphs yet have you seen that yes
yeah okay good all right that's going to
be my way in that's the easiest way to
have a look at it here's sign
okay and here is cos
right now i've just drawn the what we
call one period of each of the graphs if
i keep going i'm going to repeat the
same shape over and over again
this point here this end point is 360
degrees okay so where's 180
for this one it's right in the middle
okay for this one it happens to be down
here okay now just saving a bit of time
this is negative one okay that's the
bottom of that graph
all right so what happens well cos of
180 degrees equals the square root of
1 minus sine
squared of 180 degrees you see what i
mean by the brackets flying around okay
cos 180
1 minus
zero squared
now this was just as many lines as the
other one but remember i said that was
the easiest one okay if you think you
have found something i'll give you a
caution okay
i'll come around and have a look at your
your suggested reasons for why this is a
fallacy because it is okay
but i'll give you a tip right now i can
almost certainly tell you it's not the
first one you thought of okay if you're
like ah i see the problem there's an
obvious problem to this but it's
actually if you work through all the
mats it's not a problem there's
something a little more sneaky